This video is sponsored by Brilliant.
I want to push myself to do hard
things, although the first hard
thing is walking and carrying all
of these textbooks here in one hand.
I've locked myself in a bus out in the
Australian bush with no phone, no internet,
just a bunch of textbooks about fractals,
and I can't leave until I master this topic.
I know a little bit about fractals already
but not a lot. I know that they are these
self similar shapes that can appear a lot in
nature. I know one example would be something
like a fern plant where it's got like that
main branching shape which is similar to each
of the little leaves and and they have this
similar repeating pattern at multiple levels.
Actually, I've just seen that there's this fern
like shape here, although it's a plastic one,
but this is what I mean, that this main
shape here looks similar to each of these
little individual ones. I know of some
of the famous fractals you can draw,
and I do know that not all fractals are self
similar, that it doesn't have to be the same
pattern repeating at multiple scales, but
that there is some detail at multiple scales.
So let me give you a bus tour.
We've got the door, the window,
and the driver's seat. Here I have my stuff,
my camera, and a bunch of textbooks I got
out from the library before coming here.
A little outside deck, although I'm not
allowed to go out there. May I introduce you
to the food that I have for this challenge?
These tins of beans right here are
it. These are my rations. I have
a producer who is going to test my
knowledge by slipping some envelopes
with questions under the door. And if
I get them correct, then I get rewards
that help to make studying easier. And
if I get five correct, I get to leave.
We've got stuff about fractal dimensions,
fractals in geology and geophysics. This one
sounds interesting. Fractals, space-time,
and microphysics. The beauty of fractals.
What shape is a snowflake? Magical numbers in
nature. Fractals and multifractals in ecology
and aquatic science. But the book I'm most
looking forward to read is this one over here.
This is Mandelbrot's book on fractals called The
Fractal Geometry of Nature and since Mandelbrot
was the guy who came up with fractals
pretty much or first communicated them,
I think this one is going to have a lot of really
special knowledge in it. Mandelbrot opens with,
Why is geometry often described as cold and dry?
One reason lies in its inability to describe
the shape of a cloud, a mountain, a coastline
or a tree. Clouds are not spheres, mountains
are not cones, coastlines are not circles,
and bark is not smooth, nor does lightning travel
in a straight line. Mandelbrot says that there is
a Latin saying that to name is to know, and he
names these complex natural patterns fractals.
One of the first examples of a fractal
that Mandelbrot gives is the coastline
paradox. The coastline is surprisingly
hard to measure the length of because
there is detail at every level zooming all
the way down to the atomic sizes If you
used a small ruler and measured around
every rock you would get a much larger
answer than if you used say a Thousand
kilometer sized ruler to measure it.
There are a couple of different ways of
measuring the dimension of something the
first is topological dimension, which is
an integer value reflecting the number of
coordinates needed to specify a point within
the space. It's intuitive and straightforward,
with lines being one dimensional, and
planes two dimensional, and so forth.
Another way is the Hausdorff fractal
dimension, which extends beyond integers
to include fractional values and is a
cornerstone of fractals. It quantifies
the degree to which a fractal fills space.
This page shows some data of measuring the
length of coastlines in different places.
You can see that the coast of Britain is
especially steep in this regard compared to
attempts to measure the South African coast.
They stabilized off a bit more and a circle,
which isn't fractal, it's just an ordinary shape,
that stabilizes pretty quickly. And so it doesn't
matter if you use a smaller ruler to measure the
circle, you're going to, for the most part,
get the same result. Perhaps this means that
the coast of Britain is especially fractally and
Mandelbrot says down here that he had the idea
of using the slope of these lines as an estimate
of 1 minus D, where D is the fractal dimension.
I've just seen a wild deer. I don't
know, I've never seen one before in
Australia. I might follow it and
go have a look. Oh, there it is.
I actually love staring out of a
bus window. Just sitting there, um,
watching the world go by usually. But this is
a stationary view, which is a bit different. I
think some of my best thoughts that I've had have
just been, you know, sitting on a bus or a car,
just like looking out the window. I could do
that for ages. I am starting to really stress
actually because I don't know when the first
question is going to arrive and it could be
any minute so I'm kind of on edge and that's not
helping me to absorb the information. I've been
reading for a couple of hours now and I feel like
I don't really know if I've learned anything new.
The anxiety that I'm feeling now is kind of
hitting at why I was motivated to do this
challenge. Which is like this fear of mine
that I'm becoming not very good at doing
hard things. Even my focus is, it feels like
it's not as good as it used to be. I want to
feel like I do have a good grasp on a lot
of topics so that I can talk about them.
My worry is that the question will come and that
I'll get it wrong, and then I'll get all of them
wrong, and then this will be embarrassing and
I'll feel like I haven't learned anything and
I'll have to really go back to the drawing board.
I want this challenge to be a way for me to prove
to myself that I can still do things like
this, that I can still learn new ideas.
Here's one interesting passage I've read
so far. The fractal dimension is a measure
of the roughness of the features. Earth's
natural features are created by tectonic
processes and modified by erosion.
Erosion seems to be scale invariant,
so its influence is the same on the small
features as it is on the very large.
That's why a river network is an example of
a fractal. When the same force of nature acts
at multiple scales, we see similar features
appearing. I think the lack of yummy food is
actually affecting me more than I thought it
would. Um, when I conceived this idea of like,
just eating beans, I was like, yeah, yeah,
sounds good, sounds fine, sounds easy.
I don't know. I don't want to. I
saw Beau Miles eat a whole bunch
of beans that looked like he ate
them cold, so I feel like I can.
It's grim, but it's not too bad. Kinda tastes
normal. Okay, this is actually good. Maybe,
maybe I could actually do this. I think maybe a
problem that I have is that often to like start
work or you know, to start doing something hard,
I often wait until conditions are perfect, right?
So like I've eaten something good, it's like not
too hot, not too cold, I'm feeling not too tired.
Basically waiting and doing all these things
in my day to make it feel perfect and the right
conditions before I even start. And I can feel
myself wanting to do that. It's like hard to study
right now. It's like hard to read but I actually
want to exercise that muscle of discomfort of
pushing through and doing something hard even
when the conditions aren't perfect for me.
One thing I'd like to be able to learn is how
to calculate fractional dimensions. As you might
know, I have a passion for dimensions,
thinking about the fourth dimension,
things like this. And so, the idea
of dimensions in some sense being
these in between spaces between two and three
dimensions, between one and two, three and four,
maybe, being able to calculate and understand
what it means to be a fractional dimension.
What does it mean to be 2.5D? And lucky
for me, I've encountered a pretty simple
formula in the book to measure the fractal
dimension. The thing you are measuring,
such as the perimeter or area, should
be a given by multiplying the total
number of fragments. by the size of
each one raised to its dimension.
Let's take the area of a square for example.
It's in one piece so N is equal to one,
the length of each side is one, but we're
talking about area which is two dimensional
so D is equal to two. So the formula will
be one times one to the power of two which
is equal to one. Imagine breaking
the square up into four fragments.
Now, N is equal to four, and the length of
each of the smaller squares is one half. Still
the dimension is two, so we have four times a
half to the power of two, which is still equal
to one. This approach can be used to work out
the fractal dimension of any shape. The first
question has arrived. Okay, so this is about
the coastline paradox, which I did read about.
All right, let me just have a minute. Which
of the following statements is true regarding
measuring the length of a coastline with
a ruler? Is the dimension less than one?
I don't think so? I thought I don't know.
I don't know. I actually don't know. Let's
just see. The length of a coastline
tends to converge to a single value.
(d) In a dimension greater than one. But no,
I feel like none of these are right. Okay,
I'm panicking. I don't know. I've
got to pick something. I've got to
pick something. Uh, I'm taking too long. I'm
taking too long. I'm just gonna say A, okay,
because I'm taking too long
here. The answer is in here.
Answer is D. In a dimension greater
than one, the length of a coastline
remains almost constant as we decrease
the size of the ruler. Okay, I've gone
back to my book and found a paragraph
that explains why I got that one wrong,
but I think it does clear it up. It's this
paragraph here about the fractional dimension.
It says that the approximate measure in the
dimension D is independent of epsilon. Now
epsilon is the size of the ruler and the
measure in this case is the length of the
coastline. So if we can measure the length
of the coastline In the dimension D, which
is the fractional dimension of the coastline, then
it's independent of the size of the ruler we use.
And the fractional dimension of the
coastline happens to be about 1. 26,
so it is greater than 1. So if we look at
our question, there is indeed a dimension
greater than 1., in fact, it is at about 1. 26,
where the length of the coastline remains almost
constant. As we decrease the size of the ruler.
A previous reader of this book, even underlined
the section here, which is what was stuck
in my brain when answering this question.
It is that if you approximate the coastline's
length in a dimension smaller than its fractional
dimension, then the length will go to infinity
as the size of your ruler goes to zero. That
is the normal case where we're essentially
using an ordinary one dimensional ruler,
also known as a straight line, to
measure the length of the coastline.
We can't measure it with these one dimensional
rulers though. We need our rulers to be 1. 26
dimensional. Okay, so that was kind of a lot.
But I appreciate the question because I skimmed
over some of this stuff and I guess I didn't
really get it until now. I had just thought,
yeah yeah, small ruler, your
length will go to infinity.
Not always the case, depends on the dimension
of the ruler. What's unfortunate about getting
this first question wrong is that I
haven't received any of the rewards,
but the first one that I would receive is
fire and I do have some candles over there
and so that would allow me to get a little
bit of light for studying tonight. Yeah,
that'll kind of ruin my plans of doing more
study tonight if I'm not able to unlock this.
I found a good example of fractal dimension
of something that is not quite a line Take a
line of length one, divide it into three
parts of length one third. Just keep the
two end segments and throw the rest out, so
N is equal to two. Now repeat that process.
The remaining fragments are split into
three parts of length one over nine.
Keep the two ends of each, and you now
have four fragments. Now can we find a
dimension in which the total measure of the
line remains constant? We'll just set these
two equations equal to each other and solve
for D. Doing so results in this formula with
logarithms in it. Putting in our numbers, we
find that the dimension in which the measure
remains constant is D is equal to log 2 over
log 3, which is 0. 6309. It's less than a line,
but more than a point. This example is known
as a Cantor set. In some porous materials,
the distribution of voids can resemble the process
of removing segments. It's similar to the Cantor
set. Coral reefs grow through a process of
branching, which can also create complex,
self similar structures at different scales,
much like the iterative removal of segments.
The fractal like growth patterns of coral allow
for efficient use of space and resources, with
the intricate branching increasing surface area
for sunlight absorption and nutrient exchange.
This is exciting. Okay, another chance,
a chance to save myself. Alright,
so, okay, here's the question.
Which of the following statements is true
regarding the two definitions of dimension?
Topological dimension and hausdorff dimension.
So I did read about this earlier. I know that
it can be a fraction, and that's where we get
this idea of fractional dimensions. Okay, so,
is it A, that the topological dimension
may be an integer or a fraction?
No, because I think only the Hausdorff one can be
a fraction. B, a fractal is a set that satisfies,
um, the Hausdorff dimension being bigger
than the topological dimension. That does
ring a bell. I think I did read that. C,
the Hausdorff dimension cannot be equal
to the topological dimension.
Yeah, that seems consistent.
Wait. The Hausdorff dimension cannot be equal.
Hmm. I'm gonna go with B.
The answer is in this one.
Okay, the answer is B. Um, so that's
one, yay, okay, we're one fifth there,
we've got a reward. Okay, this is great news
because it is getting a little bit dark soon,
still light now, but we might
have some candles tonight.
I've got to confess that I am a little bit afraid
of any kind of fire, even lighting candles,
which is why I'm being so awkward in
these clips and standing over the sink.
These pictures go hard, and The Gaussian Hills
That Never Were would make for a cool album
title. But they also demonstrate that to make
video games and models look the most realistic,
fractals should be used in the simulations.
I had my dinner and did some more reading,
and then late at night on the first
day, the third question arrived.
Let's see what's in this one. Here we
go. Mandelbrot coined the term fractal
because of the following meaning. A. Fractional
dimensions. B. It is a factual way to organise
nature. C. It was inspired by branching
patterns created during fracking. And D,
it is based on the Latin fractus,
breaking into irregular fragments.
I do remember reading something
like this in the Mandelbrot book
and Mandelbrot is the guy who actually
came up with the name fractal, um,
so I believe what he has to say on the matter. So
I'll go with D, it is based on the Latin fractus,
meaning breaking into irregular fragments.
I remember that irregular fragments part
because before today, before I
was reading this Mandelbrot book
I did think it was A, I thought it
was fractional dimension, but no,
I'm gonna take Mandelbrot's word on this one,
so I'll go with D. Here is our answer. Um, okay,
that's good, that's good, that's a boost
for the morale tonight. I do get to tick
off something on the board though, and that's
going to be this one here, which is writing.
Just to be able to take notes, and I actually
get to keep the notes that I take as a bit of
a cheat sheet. It's been hard to study without
this, because it feels like just reading for
reading's sake, um, but I really find it useful
to be able to write down and organize my thoughts,
and on that I think I'm going to go
to bed pretty soon, just cause, uh,
candlelight's not quite as easy as I think
the sunlight's gonna be, so goodnight.
I got up to take a video of the deer who
was back again but then the morning got
absolutely derailed when I spotted this
spider. I had to prop the side door open
a bit to get it out but from this moment
on I was living in fear and sleeping with
one eye open. Everywhere I sit I am
now on the lookout for more spiders.
I do have one friend on board. Their name is B,
and that stands for Benoit B Mandelbrot. I might
try to explain some concepts to them later on,
but for now I'm going to leave them up here on
this curtain rail to keep a watchful eye over
me. Fun fact, algebra derives from the Arabic
word meaning the reunion of broken parts, so
fractal and algebra come from opposite meanings.
These are the note taking implements that I
am rewarded with by getting that last question
right. I just saw what I think was two foxes
going past the window, so that was pretty cool.
It's nearly four o'clock and I've been studying
all day with no questions coming through. So I've
received a heads up that the next question will
be based on two chapters from a particular book.
And it's pretty good that the next question
is from here because I've been reading this
one. I found that it has really clicked with
me in a way that the Mandelbrot book didn't.
I had this tiny tinge of disappointment that I
won't walk away from this challenge feeling like
I know fractals, instead I'll be feeling like
there's so much more to learn. Fractals are a
big topic that impact so many different fields,
right? I've been reading some of these books and
I'm just amazed by the amount of different places
that fractals show up that I had no idea about.
Like in this book here. There was a chapter about,
fractals like in mining and gold deposits and
I was reading that chapter and realized that
just trying to understand that chapter could
be an entire challenge video of its own and
that there's definitely entire careers to be
made out of studying fractals and even just
some of the use cases in which they appear.
This does kind of make me feel like
I'm cramming I'm sort of bit of an
anxiety that there is a time pressure,
that there are questions arriving any
minute. And so I'm a little worried that
I will forget a lot of this content,
but without doing this I wouldn't have made
much progress through these books at all.
So I'm hoping that at least something sticks,
and that at least some new ideas start to form
and that I can build on them later if I want to.
It's very quiet out here, very still.
It's a little bit boring in some sense,
but in another way, there's no place I'd
rather be. Here it is. I don't want to
open it. I feel like I'm not ready. Like I, I
want to feel more prepared. Um, I don't know.
This is the state of my cheat sheet of notes
when the question arrived, so it wasn't full.
I was like, still planning to
make some more notes down here.
Okay. You measure the length of the coastline
of three different islands. Island X, Y,
and Z using four different rulers with
links 10cm, 1m, 100m, and 1km. Each ruler
gives a different result and you plot them on
a graph. Which statement is false? This is kind
of like that graph that I showed you yesterday
actually, where one of the gradients was flat,
and that was for a circle, which isn't fractal
at all? For a non fractal shape, it like,
at least levels off, or is flat. D. Island Z
has a smoother coastline than island Y. Wait,
no, yeah, okay, that's the one
that's false. I'm gonna say D.
Yeah, it can't be smoother than Y, it
just can't, it can't be smoother than Y.
Answer D. Yes, okay, okay, this is great,
this is great. I'll also be able to use real
lights from now on, um, the overhead lights,
which is gonna be great for my eyes. This
is a really small joy, but I need it.
This actually smells great and looks really
good. No, it actually looks really good today,
I like it. If I had some cheese and rice to go
with this, it wouldn't be a grim meal at all.
It would actually be one of my favourite meals.
The sooner I can escape the bus and go outside,
the better. I love being in here and learning,
and I love learning about fractals, but,
you know, it hurts to be out here, but then
locked in a bus. It's like I'm in nature,
but so close yet so far. To be honest, I think
if I was able to go outside and do walks and do
things and, and be more in control of my life,
I think I would actually study better. I don't
think that all of these hours that I've
spent in here have been productive hours.
Many of them have been, I think,
non productive. I don't think what
I'm doing is the best or far
from the only way to learn.
I was just taking a minute
to stare at the ceiling,
but I heard another envelope get dropped off.
I'm excited, but I'm also nervous. Um, I've still
got my same cheat sheet with me from earlier. Um,
okay. We can do this. We can do this. This should
be good. Alright. I really love opening these.
You are taking a random walk when you notice an
odd looking tree. Examining one of its leaves,
you determine it can be constructed the
following way. In each iteration A,B,C,
all side lengths are equal. What
is the fractal dimension? I've
got a couple of formulas that help
me calculate the fractal dimension.
What I need to know is how many fragments
it's been broken up into and, like,
the size of each of those fragments. Yeah, that,
that would have to make sense, that
it's been broken into one, two, three.
What I needed to do was just look at the first
order change. We started with 4 lines of length 1,
then squares are added into each fragment. We
now have 20 lines of length one third, since
3 fit along the original side. Put those
numbers into the logarithm formula to find
that D is log 5 over log 3. But I muddled up
the bottom and got log 1/3 instead of log 3.
This caused me to panic and
enter a tailspin for 20 minutes,
trying various other techniques which would
have worked had I not made more basic errors.
Eventually I picked log 5 over log 3 because I
could tell it was close to my answer in form,
and I knew it was in the right ballpark,
even if I couldn't explain the discrepancy.
Yes! Yes! Okay, it says C. I've
been solving this for like half
an hour. We're ticking off technology and here
are my rewards. My phone and my laptop. Okay,
I get to use these and I get to connect to
the internet for the next part. I received
a message that the next question would
be about the Mandelbrot set so I did
some googling and even watched a
few Numberphile videos about it.
I found that understanding the Mandelbrot
set starts with understanding the behavior
of numbers when you square them. Some numbers
when you square them blow up and go to infinity,
but not all numbers. One stays the
same no matter how many times you
square it. And numbers less than one will
actually decrease if you square them.
The Mandelbrot set explores this line
between stable and unstable points,
where unstable points are those ones
that blow up to infinity. In particular,
the Mandelbrot set is defined by this iterative
formula that starts at zero. You square it and
then add a complex number onto it to get
the starting point for the next iteration.
If C, the complex number that you're adding each
time, causes the value to blow up to infinity,
then C is not in the Mandelbrot set. If instead C
causes the value to go to some stable fixed point,
or to zero for example, then C is in
the Mandelbrot set. To see what I mean,
let's take a look at a few numbers and
see if they are in the Mandelbrot set.
Let's take one. Starting with 0 squared
plus 1, that's 1. Square 1 and add 1
and you get 2. Square that and add 1 and you
get 5. Square that and add 1 and you get 26.
And it will keep going to infinity. So 1 is not
in the Mandelbrot set. Let's try i, which is the
square root of minus 1. 0 plus i is i. Then
i squared plus i is equal to minus 1 plus i.
Then square that and add i, and it actually works
out to be just minus i. Square that and add i,
and again you'll get minus 1 plus i, and
you'll continue toggling between these
values. So i is in the Mandelbrot set. In this
shape here, anywhere that is black is a point
in the Mandelbrot set, and the colored
points are ones that go off to infinity,
but they're colored based on how
quickly they go off to infinity.
It's a very interesting mathematical
pattern. When you zoom in on various parts,
you will find the shape repeats. It
is fractal because there is repeating
detail and self similar structures at
every scale. It has a fractal dimension
of about 1. 3. It's more than a line,
but not enough to be a filled in shape.
It's amazing the complexity that comes out of
this thing, because fundamentally it's defined by
quite a simple rule. This artwork is made by just
marking points that, when squared and then added
to themselves in an iterative way, remain stable.
So I'm feeling a little bit down, actually,
because I realized that I got the previous
question right, but not because I actually
got it right, more that I got it close enough
and, and essentially guessed the right answer.
Um, and I've had time to go and think
and realize how it was done and where I
actually made a mistake. I used a three
instead of a third anyway, and then I,
I used something else wrong the second time, so I
did all this working and I, I got close enough and
I got the answer, so I'm going to allow it. And,
you know, guessing is allowed in, in this game.
I've designed in the sense that it's multi-choice
for a reason if you don't know you should have
a 1/4 chance of getting it right. So I got it
right but I feel like I really had two or more
brain farts in the process of doing that working
out and so for that reason I'm going to call it
quits for today, go to bed and hope that I'm a
little bit fresher and more onto it tomorrow.
I've just got out of bed this morning to
find one more question and this could be
the last one. There's no answer in this
one. Okay. Visit brilliant. org. Navigate
to complex numbers slash the
Mandelbrot set. Complete the
final question correctly to escape the bus.
This question is sponsored by Brilliant.
Brilliant is an interactive way to learn
math, data science, and computer science.
What I like about Brilliant is that I get
to test my knowledge by answering questions,
which helps me feel like I actually
understand what I'm reading. Their
courses are also fun and allow
you to work at your own pace.
Their course on complex numbers covers the
Mandelbrot set and the related Julia sets
by first covering the properties of complex
numbers which are important to understanding
these particular fractals. You can get started
on Brilliant for free for 30 days and the first
200 people get 20 percent off an annual plan
by visiting brilliant.org/tibees. If a point
C is in the main carteoid, then the process
of squaring and adding eventually results in
a single fixed point Z such that Z squared
plus C is equal to Z. If X is a real number
in the mandelbrot set, what's the maximum
value of X? Oh my God, this is quite hard.
One half is the largest of these numbers,
so that seemed like a good place to start.
Initially I tried to just see what happened
if I squared these numbers then added them
to themselves, to see if that would be stable
or not. But after several iterations of this
Mandelbrot function, I would have a
number that wouldn't really tell me
definitively if it would keep getting
bigger or converge to some fixed value.
And so it wasn't clear without doing a
lot more iterations what would be the
long term behavior of these things. So
I ended up using the hint on Brilliant,
which gave me this equation that Z
squared plus X is equal to Z. Initially,
I didn't see how this would help, but I
realized this is to do with the fixed point.
What I mean is for numbers that are
going into this Mandelbrot function,
either they will blow up to infinity or
they might oscillate around a stable point,
a fixed point. So some value that
it converges to, no matter how many
times you put it into this function. In this
equation, that fixed point is represented by Z.
It's saying that if you've done enough
iterations to reach this final fixed point,
then you square it and add your number on,
you should end up still at that fixed point.
So I just need to find which one of these four
fractions is the largest one that satisfies this
equation. That seems kind of tricky, and starting
with putting 0.5 in just to see what happens,
we get this quadratic, which actually doesn't have
any real solutions. You could try to complete the
square or use the quadratic formula on this, but
the only Z that you'd find which satisfied it
would have an imaginary component. So let's
try the next biggest one, which is a third.
Putting a third in leads to the same problem,
that there is no real solution for Z in this
quadratic equation. The next one to try is one
quarter and rearranging it to have Z squared
minus Z plus a quarter being equal to zero,
you could complete the square quite easily
actually and find a Z value of a half.
That's pretty cool, and we can see that it
works. If you're already at the point one half or
0. 5, and you square that, it becomes one quarter
or 0. 25, which is how much you're adding back on,
so you're going to end up with what you
started with, 0. 5. And no matter how many
more iterations of the Mandelbrot function
you do from this point, you will stay there.
The largest real number in the Mandelbrot
set is also the point on the real axis that
is furthest to the right. So this red dot
here in the picture above the question,
that's what I'm saying should be one
quarter and eyeballing it with the
axes that are given here looks about
right too. So I'm gonna go with that.
I'm nervous because I really want to go.
I wanted to make a graceful and profound
exit, like they do on The Bachelor when
they slowly step out of the car.
Instead, this is the exit I made.
Running in fear from what is objectively a
tiny threat. Oh my god. I have a big problem
on the oh my god. This is the final boss.
If it jumps on me, I'm dead. I am dead.
I'm just going. I'm going. I'm going.
I'm going. I'm going. . Oh my god. Oh
my god, I've been craving something
like this for a while. How do I eat
it? That's really good. I don't think
I became an expert on fractals. I think
maybe I learned enough to be able to
sustain a conversation about them.
But I feel far from being an expert. In
fact it was the simple things that nearly
defeated me on this challenge. Logarithms
and the quadratic formula. So if anything
I could just spend three days out here
relearning the basics of maths. But um
I'm glad I did it. It was fun to do. I look
forward to doing something like this again.
See you next time and thank you to my
Patreon supporters for making these videos
possible. Shoutout to today's Patreon
cats of the day, Duchess and Princess.
​